firstly we'll need to update our parse
atlas definition function to take into
account if a sprite has been trimmed
using this data to modify the corner X
and corner y offset values this is
important because if you recall the
coordinate system of the canvas will
place an image according to its top-left
corner
well the trimming process and texture
Packer can move the top-left corner to
the new trim location as such we need to
refer to the trim data against the
source data to figure out what the
proper offset is to draw the sprite in
the correct location with this in mind
you need to update the parse atlas
definition to take into account the
differences between the framed version
and the source version to properly
update the offset values so that the
sprite draws in the right location